[ __ ] carlson exposing the horrible
consequences of sovereign crime policies
ruining america's second biggest city
the suicide of los angeles is streaming
right now on fox nation here's a preview
i never saw a district attorney despair
fabio lozoni is an actor and a long time
resident of los angeles he moved out
after his home was burglarized twice he
was a district attorney of san francisco
and he destroyed san francisco and now
you're moving to los angeles so he can
destroy los angeles
the crime in los angeles becomes so bad
every time you turn the tv on there are
a lot of questions about home security
and how to keep yourself safe
i've been a bit of a crime to burglarize
my my house a couple times what happened
to the criminals who burglarized your
house were they arrested and convicted
no not yet
trucker joins us now to tell us more so
tucker i thought that the special was
very aptly named by saying the suicide
of los angeles considering that george
gascon
was voted into his current position
that's right i mean it was it was an
intentional act it's a huge city it's a
very complicated cities to see that's
changed a lot so there are a lot of
causes of the disorder that you see
but the main one is really easy to trace
there is
the main prosecutor in the in the city
of los angeles has stopped prosecuting
violent crimes
so you don't have to guess about what's
going to happen we knew what was going
to happen he knew it was going to happen
he did it anyway and an awful lot of
people have died this is an act of
cruelty
and we should we should say that out
loud judge
you know tucker
having having a prosecutor who is woke
is almost worse than having no
prosecutor at all because what he is
doing is he's letting people out of jail
ahead of time and there is no obviously
they're not adding any kind of
special circumstances we call it but i'm
trying to think who has the most
leverage here are the business people in
the community people that might have
leverage i mean they know ultimately
they need votes
well there's a kind of moral shame that
has paralyzed stakeholders in los
angeles you're a bad person if you're
against allowing violent criminals to
commit violent crimes the problem with
this long term is not just that a lot of
people have died and are dying now
probably as we speak the problem is that
this
this is the end of the whole system
prosecutor is supposed to be on one side
defense turning the other is you no
judge
if you have the prosecutor and the
defense attorney both on the side of the
criminals then you drive people to
self-defense to vigilante justice people
can't count on the state to protect them
they will protect themselves because
people will protect their families and
you're going to start to see extra
judicial killings in los angeles period
yep no question about that vigilante and
and then the kyle rittenhouse effect
that's right all right harold
tucker uh nice to see you as you as you
went through this did you
walk away with maybe some ideas that
gascon should be pursuing i know i mean
they're they're those who want guns off
the street they're those who want more
more more cops on the street more
training for police officers
i agree with you we have to prosecute
crimes and it seems like gascon is
facing some political pressure but were
there other ideas outside of that that
uh you're reporting and your series uh
has has revealed
well this isn't really space travel i
mean these are issues that human beings
have dealt with since they left the
caves or even before how do you deter
the people you live with from hurting
you and you punish them if they do and
the punishment is swift and certain it's
called deterrence you do it with your
kids you do it with your dogs and this
is how all living things learn like
touch the stove get burned and so we
know what to do just enforce the laws
that the public creates by voting that's
our system has been for hundreds of
years he's the one i mean just like
restore what we had and things will be
fine that's that's the answer sean so
tucker we can see the consequences um
and we saw that in part of your um uh in
your segment but i think the question is
why is this happening why why is he
doing this i mean if you don't have rule
of law you have degradation of society
you don't have a country if you don't
have rule of law and this is a george
soros funded prosecutor is this about
destroying america this is not about
justice is it no it's about punishment
of course it's by the way it's not all
of this
exists under the banner of helping the
underdog you know the have-nots are
going to get what's coming to them you
know you can kind of support it maybe i
mean there are a lot of have-nots in
this country and i'm mostly of the time
on their side they're not benefiting
poor people people in black
neighborhoods hispanic neighbors they're
not benefiting at all in fact they're
the main victims of this the point of
this is to punish the haves this is an
act of aggression against the
stakeholders in los angeles and chicago
and new york this is trying to hurt
people not help them and i wish we would
just say that because it's so very
obvious greg
uh hey tucker i got two questions for
you number one uh quite obviously you're
on fox nation this is a special uh fox
nation is a streaming success yes uh now
that cnn plus is defunct has fox nation
considered rehiring chris wallace for
fox nation we could probably get him at
a discount and he i've seen that he
interviews a lot of very interesting
people that's my first question but i
can we had a meeting about it this
morning in my office and i was like i
was like no he just failed and one of my
producers goes you know he's mike
wallace's son
he's got to be good all right hey so i
want to ask you about there is some hope
in california
and i and i i've been following and
talking to michael shellenberger i was
wondering what your thoughts were about
he's running for governor against gavin
newsom he's unusual in the fact that he
already has solutions which is quite
rare but i just cons what your thoughts
were shellenberger is amazing what an
interesting smart guy
who actually has the most revealing
documentary series i've ever seen with
his iphone on homelessness ever explains
why we have it i mean the problem with
california is so many reasonable people
just gave up and left well you and me
and like millions of others like us who
grew up in the state it's people like
shellenberger who are staying and
fighting to improve it to reclaim it
that are going to save the state i'm
really rooting for him strongly
all right chucker it's great to see you
and thank you for bringing americans
this crucial reporting and uh allocation
of everything that's going on thank you
kenny pavlich thank you thank you great
to see you
check out the suicide of los angeles
streaming now on fox nation
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight